und noch mehr platz brauchen
beispielsweise die angehörigen der
fraktion von bündnis 90 die grünen denn
sie sind deutlich mehr geworden und das
bedeutet britta haßelmann bisherige
erste parlamentarische geschäftsführerin
der fraktion und mutmaßlich auch
zukünftige nehme ich mal an zumindest
für unterstelle ich mal da weiterhin ein
großes interesse an dieser aufgabe das
bedeutet für die fraktion auch dass sie
wahrscheinlich umziehen müssen demnächst
was das fraktions so was den
fraktionssaal angeht denn der wo in dem
sie bislang waren wir nicht hinreichen
das stimmt wir wissen nur noch nicht wo
aber heute tagen wie andere fraktionen
im plenarsaal denn bei uns ist es auch
so die alte und die neue fraktion kommen
heute noch mal zusammen einerseits um
sich zu verabschieden voneinander und
andererseits sicht zu begrüßen wir sind
abgeordnete der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen haben 16 direktmandate erzielt so
groß war die fraktion noch nie
verstrahlt sie ja das strahle ich
natürlich und die heißen wir heute alle
gekommen und wer die ersten diskussionen
führen darüber wie die ausgangslage für
uns ist und ich freue mich einfach das
wird so intakt des willkommens
konstituierung der neuen fraktion wird
unterschiedlich gehandhabt wird auch an
unterschiedlichen tagen stattfinden sie
haben gerade gesagt bei ihnen heute
nicht was er bedeutet die konstituierung
denn bei ihnen ja das heißt natürlich
also wie gesagt heute alte neue fraktion
dann wahrscheinlich schon im laufe
dieser woche dann die konstituierende
sitzung der neuen fraktion der 20
wahlperiode mit den neuen 118
abgeordneten und dann werden wir uns
eine vorläufige geschäftsordnung geben
damit wir einfachen rahmen haben wie wir
zusammenarbeiten als fraktion und dann
werden wir natürlich erst mal die
sondierungsgespräche die jetzt
stattfinden abwarten viele der
abgeordneten kommen hier natürlich jetzt
neu erst mal an dh die bundestags
ausweise und und alles was man sich so
vorstellen kann zum auftakt der
zwanzigster wahlperiode findet jetzt in
diesen stunden und tagen erst mal statt
fdp fraktion hat gestern schon getagt
das hat schon eine kleine tradition
zumindest vor vier jahren hatte die
fdp-fraktion das ähnlich gemacht damals
übrigens im genscher haus weil da noch
gar kein platz für die fdp-fraktion hier
war die ja in der legislaturperiode
davor nicht im parlament gewesen ist nun
hatten die fdp fraktion ihren
vorsitzenden schon bestätigt auch die
stellvertreter und eine parlamentarische
geschäftsführer was werden sie
bestätigen in dieser woche
beziehungsweise schon wählen wählen sie
überhaupt schon also wir werden die
geschäftsordnung natürlich uns geben und
wir werden dann mit der fraktion darüber
sprechen ob wir den fraktionsvorstand
die erstmal kommissarisch einsetzen
solange diese sondierungsphase besteht
und dann sehen wir einfach weiter aber
das wird alles entschieden wenn die neue
fraktion zusammen kommt ich freue mich
riesig darauf und genau die diskussion
zwischen den fraktionen dann wie wir die
ganzen parlamentarischen abläufe
gestalten vor ältestenrat wird sich
irgendwann treffen weil es ja noch keine
neu zusammengesetzte koalition gibt und
auch die frage wann findet die
konstituierende sitzung des deutschen
bundestages staaten noch nicht 100
prozent klar ist bevor wir auf den einen
oder anderen aktuellen politischen punkt
gucken vielleicht auch noch mal einen
kleinen einblick in ihre arbeit denn das
so viel mehr abgeordnete bedeutet ja
auch eine menge
organisatorischer arbeit die jetzt auf
sie zukommen lassen uns mal kurz kleine
haben was das konkret bedeutet ja also
erstmal ist es zu dass wir haben jetzt
natürlich nicht den 26 98 abgewartet und
gedacht oh wer kommt da jetzt alles
sondern haben mit vielen potenziellen
abgeordneten neuen abgeordneten auch
vorher schon gespräche geführt wir haben
ein willkommens team wir haben
einfach sehr viele diskussionen und
informationsveranstaltungen schon
gemacht für die neue kommenden
abgeordneten und heute wird das auch so
was sein so eine mischung zwischen
einerseits information
und natürlich auch die ersten
politischen diskussion in einer fraktion
und am abend gibt es dann auch noch ein
kleines zusammentreffen und die
fachpolitischen sprecher gewinnen werden
dann in einer der folgenden sitzung
gewählt das kann da durchaus noch ein
bisschen dauern so was wartet alles noch
das folgt ja immer auch so im prinzip
wie sind die ausschüsse also wieviel
ausschüsse wird es am ende geben
und das wird ja alles aufgabe sein die
erst klar und deutlich wird nach einer
bildung einer koalition ich hoffe dass
wir das bis dezember abgeschlossen
kriegen und nicht so lange warten müssen
auch hier mit dem start in die
parlamentarische arbeit
wie bei der letzten regierungsbildung in
der 19 millionen bildung der neuen
koalition ist ein schönes stichwort denn
es gibt in diesen tagen so genannte
vorsortierung haben wir bislang auch
noch mich können sie uns zum einen
bestätigen dass es tatsächlich ab morgen
dann beginnen soll zwischen fdp und
grünen spitze das werden gespräche
geführt zwischen unseren
parteivorsitzenden annalena baerbock und
robert habeck mit der fdp mit der spd
und möglicherweise auch mit der cdu/csu
um einfach auszuloten wo stehen die alle
und dass es hier an der stelle einen pre
gibt für eine mögliche ampel ist auch
klar wenn man sich die schnittmengen
ansieht mit der spd aber wir haben
deutlich gemacht beredten natürlich mit
allen demokratischen kräften der
regierungsauftrag oder die bildung einer
regierung liegt ja offenkundig nicht bei
der cdu csu dass es auch deutlich
geworden durch das wahlergebnis möchte
jetzt ganz speziell diese sogenannten
vor sondierung woher grüne und fdp erst
mal zusammenkommen wollten um zu gucken
wo sind denn eigentlich gemeinsamkeiten
um dann zu auszuloten
ob man dann überhaupt in weitere
gespräche geht ob es überhaupt sinn hat
der spiegel berichtet dass die morgen
stattfinden sollen es gibt es offiziell
noch keine bestätigung können sie uns
das bestätigen dass es morgen losgeht
und wenn ich sie richtig verstanden
haben wir mit die fraktionsspitze noch
nicht dabei sein und da ich auch nicht
dabei sein werde genau sondern die
parteivorsitzenden annalena baerbock und
robert habeck kann ich das genaue datum
nicht nennen aber die gespräche werden
stattfinden jetzt auch zeitnah und ich
finde das ganz gut weil wir grüne haben
einen klaren auftrag dieser auftrag des
größer als unser ergebnis wir sind mit
14,8 prozent aus dieser bundestagswahl
herausgegangen drittstärkste kraft und
dass wir jetzt auch mal mit der fdp
ausloten wo sind eigentlich die ganz
großen kontroversen zwischen uns
programmatisch und wo gibt es vielleicht
auch gemeinsamkeiten finde ich ganz gut
denn wir warten nicht einfach nur darauf
dass uns einer einlädt und das ganze
lenkt habe ich heute immer noch gestern
darüber nachgedacht wäre 20 17 auch
nicht so falsch gewesen oder mal vorher
zu gucken wo man überhaupt zusammen
kommen kann und will ja aber so eine
rückbetrachtung habe ich ehrlich gesagt
in mir jetzt gar nicht gegönnt weil es
gerade so viel zu tun nach vorne für die
regierungsbildung der zwanzigsten
wahlperiode ich finde auf jeden fall
sehr eindeutig wir grüne haben einen
auftrag der hs klimaschutz in dieser
bundesregierung zu verankern und alles
was damit verbunden ist die
transformation der wirtschaft auch die
fragen von gerechtigkeit und ich bin
gespannt wir sind auf jeden fall sehr
gut vorbereitet britta haßelmann vielen
dank dass sie uns einen kleinen einblick
gegeben haben in das was den nächsten
tagen und wochen auf uns zukommt aber
vor allem auch auf sie und insbesondere
auch auf die fraktion insgesamt die neue
die bislang größte bündnis 90 grüne
fraktion im deutschen bundestag vielen
dank